yeah set the hour so let's get started
let's see if this still works yes all
right hi everybody my name is rob i'm
very glad that you're still uh here
looking into how we can use github
actions with security in mind
since this is a security conference i do
need to prefix this a little bit it's
not much so much implementing security
practices with github actions it's just
focusing on github actions themselves we
all run in cicd pipelines these days at
least i hope all of you are doing
something with devops there
i've been using github action since the
beta in 2019 and i've been always been
fascinated with my ci cd pipelines of
how the hell do we secure those things
and then when something news comes along
get up actions then that is something
for me to dive deeper into
and that is how decision came to be
before we get started we're here is
already using github actions for ci cd
or other things
just a couple of hands all right then
i'll give a little bit more insight into
what they can do and what you can do
there with them
um
yeah
so to get started
it's nice that github made a
product name and they named it github
actions and the things that you actually
run are then actions
but the file that we store we call that
a workflow because the workflow is what
we use to call a pipeline
so naming is hard even at github when it
wasn't a yet part of microsoft now they
are so you could say the naming of
microsoft is hard of course
but the workflow is our pipeline
definition that we have
and they will execute one or more
actions for us
and the workflows are triggered by
events anytime something happens inside
of github it can trigger a workflow and
that is why we call it a workflow
another pipeline
usually cicd systems ash devils for
example or gitlab they have pipelines
because they are focusing on cicd
with github actions it's a generic
workflow and you can do lots and lots of
cool things with it inside of the gita
platform
from there you can call different apis
and call out to your cloud platform for
example and for that we have lots of
events available i think there's 35
different events that you can trigger
your workflow with when somebody creates
an issue when somebody comes in on the
pull request you can then do something
with that so it's great for automating
everything that you can
that's the difference from from other ci
cd systems
the actions then themselves are the
small steps in the workflows small
building blocks that usually do one
thing and one thing only
in the basis it's just a shell script it
will start execute something for you and
then you can do
your the things that you need to do if
it's a deployment into your cloud
environment if to run a static security
tool for example in the basis it's all
scripts
you can create your own but you can also
use an existing one from the marketplace
that means we have those building blocks
available in the platform you can build
on top of that to create your entire
workflow file that does something for
you
for example your ci cd pipeline and in
there you can include your static code
analysis tooling for example and do
something there
we currently have 12 and a half thousand
actions available in the marketplace
this is the way the github of course
works they say we have something and we
create that as an open source module
and the whole community can then help
improve that setup and contribute
actions back to them
from now we've seen an explosion if you
compare this to azure devops what i was
previously working with there's
something like three and a half thousand
extensions in the marketplace after all
those years of tfs vsts and devops india
so there's an explosion using the power
of the community
anything you can think of it's probably
available in the marketplace you can
readily download it and start using it
at least that's what all the demos say
and that's what i'm here to tell you
please try to not do that if you can
an example of a workflow definition i
picked something that i work a lot with
that's a little net core
and it starts with that file it's a text
based file which means it gets a part of
your repository and it has history
from the history we can do this and we
can all do the good practices of having
multiple people to review changes for
example take ownership of those files
it has to be stored inside of the github
slash workflows folder
if any of those things has a typo it
will not work and it will take you 15
minutes before you figure out how that
happened
ask me how i know of course
it's a text based files yeah i'm also
indentation here matters
my guess is that people already know a
little bit about that
you can see the trigger in here in this
case we're triggering somebody pushes
code back into the github repository
and from there you run what you run one
or multiple jobs this guy's got one that
does the build and deploy in one job and
we're pushing in this case to a label on
an environment that we call production
in there we have an array of steps
and the steps are then the actual
building blocks and whenever it's a user
statement that means that it comes it is
an actual action and actions are stored
inside of a repository
and you can start building on top of
that if you see a run command then it's
just a call into your shell that the
runner is executing for you
i think you can have that in here and
start with the most used action that
this is in the out there that's a
checkout action download the source code
of the repository that you're running
against download all that on your runner
environment
and then you can start doing things this
already is the main difference with
other csicd systems most cisd systems
say we start at your source code
so you don't have an opportunity to say
i don't want the source code because i'm
automating something else in github you
need to specifically say i want my
source code otherwise i can just run a
different script without downloading my
repository
then we have a setup action in this case
the installs.net core with a specific
version for this demonstration
and then we run the shell script please
execute me a dotnet build and there are
more stuff beneath this of course but
this is the overall example of how a
workflow is structured and how it
operates so for the people who haven't
been using actions you now at least have
a vision of
how these things work and operate if
there are questions in between just ask
them
i can try to help there
so for the security perspective i want
to dive a little bit deeper into the
main three topics on top
how can we secure our repositories and
who can uh write to them
and what is in there
we'll dive also into the runners those
are the things that are actually
executing your workflow files on azure
dev site was agents for example i think
in gitlab they're called runners as well
and then we look into actions and how
you can do secure operations there
from that i've got some best practices
that i always like to advise people to
follow along with that
but first repository security and it all
starts with who the hell has access to
our source code who has the
authorizations there to create things
and this is a little bit of an easy
overview there
inside of get it we have always access
levels that you can set up at the lowest
level for the repository you can say for
this repository that person can write to
it for example and then you have a roll
up to organization level and then even a
robot to enterprise
in that setup you have different
permission levels
and it starts on the top with no access
but if you have a public repository on
github.com anyone who can go to that
page doesn't have any access but they
can already see your source code
so they can start diving into what are
the components of your source code
and see different
attack patterns for example they can try
to figure it out
anybody has read only access
on public repositories as soon as they
have logged into github.com
now with read access on that level
you get access to anything inside of the
repository this is the source code
itself the history that is in there but
also the log files when you're executing
your actions
so be very aware of when you're on a
public repository that those log files
will be visible as well
up over there we've got three hours
levels where you can actually manage
some issues and do some triaging there
but you don't have right access yet and
the maintain is interesting because
that's between full access as an admin
and write access but they don't have
access to sensitive data
for example security alerts coming from
one of the security tools inside of
github
and they cannot do things like deleting
releases from a repository or
renamed the
entire repository itself for example
it's really easy to start configuring
access and see who has access if you're
on the organization level here i'm here
at a community event that we
do every year
under the people tab you can find some
information there
you can create teams and from teams you
can see who are the people who have
access in those teams
if you then dive in deeper into a user
you can go to the user itself and find
out that hey this person is owner that's
my account on that organization
and that means that it has admin access
to all the repositories in that
organization
and then you can even specify um
the list of those repositories specify
the teams that that person is in and
find out more information in this case
in some admin at the org level i can see
every repository that is in there
but it's a good start to at least know
who has access to your source code yeah
question
you said it was
like on public repo but is it the same
if you have a pilot no then you need to
be logged in and only then if you have
access then you can see it so there are
three different levels it's public
that's the default one
private is only if you have been invited
and you have an internal one if you're
part of an organization and you can see
all the internal repositories
yeah good one
if i don't notice your hands very hard
for me to see with the lies here so then
shout out
second step is workflow secrets we've
seen this in different ci cd systems as
well and github actions has a secret
store as well that you can use
but it's very good to know how that
thing works
really warm here so let me see if i can
do this without killing the audio
audio still long
all right
the secrets um you can pull that in it's
a text-based file so we have weird
annotations with accolades and a dollar
sign to pull in a context and then
a constant name in this case the name of
the secret and then you can pull in the
value of a secret stored in the secret
store
into the execution and runtime of your
environment you can create these at the
application at the repository level or
at the organization level
and they're actually secrets
they're encrypted side with a public key
before they are ever reached get up
before they reach and get up on their
side
if you have the the level of access that
you need to be able to create a secret
then you can download the public key and
you need to encrypt it with the rest api
before you can post it so it's an actual
secret stored in the sodium box
and it also means that you as a user
cannot decrypt it
there are ci cd systems where you can
still pull out that information like
gitlab for example and after the fact
read out what the value of that secret
is
so this is nice it's actually a secret
and if you use get it before then you
know any public repository can be forked
and that means that extra metadata a lot
of the secrets are not getting forked
with that fork over
um so
what the the person who forks gets only
the source code that is in there and
nothing of the history or the logs for
example and also not access to your
secrets
and creating secrets has some stringent
requirements be for you are able to do
that so you need to be a repository
owner then you can create secrets
and you can update and delete them
so anybody who is a maintainer doesn't
have access to the list of secrets that
they can use
but they can still implement the
workflow file and get those values
inserted into the workflow as well
you can also create an organization
level
that means you need to have admin access
to the entire organization before
because in there
you can set access policies which
repositories are able to see those
secrets and what can you do with it
together three options you have access
for all the repositories or only private
ones
or a subset of them and it's nice
because then you can do all the
aggregation at the organization level
you only have to maintain one version of
the secret and if you do some key
rotation you can do that there as well
i said they are encrypted
but only until you start using them and
this is a downfall of most ci cd systems
and i don't see a way around that when
you start executing your workflow you
need access to those secrets so you need
to start injecting them into the process
that is executing in this case the
actions and they're either injected as
an environment variable or as direct
input for an action each action on this
side lives inside of its own process on
the runner
and we give that process then access to
a secret in this case
github tries to redact that secret value
out into the logs
they do a regular expression there
and that means they're using a regular
expression there that means if you do
you structure data with spaces in there
and accolades and xml stuff that's very
hard to redact so be very aware of what
you input into those secrets
if it already has multi lines then you
need to start thinking about
as i said
they're injected as plain text for the
actions which also means the actions can
do anything with them
they can decide to spool it off through
a third-party api endpoint and all of a
sudden your cloud keys are now gone
so be very aware of what kind of actions
you implement inside of your workload
file
and as i said anybody would access the
action log so any authenticated user
against the public repository that's
usually the the modus operandi of open
source it's a public repository
they can see those log files
and if you're inputting their json or
other structured data that might be an
issue to redact then all of a sudden
those values might be visible
i've got an example here on the left
side side
echoing out a secret the demo log in
this case
and then on the
bottom line i'm doing something sneaky
i'm adding a space after each character
in the secret all right
if you are logged in to github.com
you've got access to public uh
repositories and their action logs
so you can see those logs
and getting an account on github.com is
really just giving him the username and
password and you're in
they don't even validate the email
address at the moment so it's really
easy to get a user account
if you start doing things then they will
need to validate your email address but
creating an account is really super
simple
what happens when echo out that value
the first one is actually uh
confu obfuscated because they've output
those stars because the regular
expression worked
but if i do something simple like adding
a space after each character the regular
expression fails and now my secret has
been stored
has been leaked into the log file
so be very aware of what you're trying
to do with those secrets
what we currently have is for example if
you want to deploy into a cloud
environment we have an openid connect
situation there we can configure that at
for example the resource group in azure
and you can say this specific workload
file from this repository on this branch
can publish my application into that
resource group that's a way better
situation to start using
we're only building up that momentum
right now and it's not available inside
of github yet so if you're using secrets
be very aware of what the actions are
doing with them because it's really easy
to spool them out into the log file
and we have seen cases where developers
say i don't have the keys to deploy into
production it sucks i have found a way
to output this into my system
and it used to start with base64 but
this is a way easier trick and you don't
have to decode it
so be aware of what you do with those
secrets
and that's only for access to your code
and workflow sequence
even worse you store your own code
inside of the repository and with your
own code i really mean anything inside
of your repository that will be
available for the workflow when it is
executed
it starts with the definition of your
workflow file what kind of actions are
you using what do you download there
the runner that is executing your
workflow
will see the list of actions that it
needs to get and an action is stored
inside of a public repository
the first thing that the runner does is
download that entire repository into the
execution environment and start running
from there
you download an entire repository with
all the source code in there all the
repositories if there are binary
binaries in a repository the runner is
downloading that for you
so be very aware of what you put into
your workflow files
even the shell scripts that we make for
our make files
executing the builds for ourselves
those are potential attack factors as
well
even your own code you never know what
kind of developers you have in the house
do you trust them fully
to do everything in a good way even if
they are gruntled employees and leave in
the next week
be very aware of what is in there as
well and then of course dependencies i
talked about this yesterday in a session
on supply chain management
we don't reinvent the wheel i hope you
build on top of packages most of those
packages are open source
and you start using them as well but we
need to be aware of what is in those
packages as well
so it starts with some set of code
analysis on your own code
but also some validations on the
packages that you use
supply chain management issues are
becoming more and more worse
and depending on which research you
follow
you could say that 99 of the code that
you use is not yours
it comes from those public packages
because these are they are usually
entire libraries of stuff that you don't
want to write yourself
it also goes for the whole supply chain
setup your dependencies need to be kept
up to date we probably all heard the
term bit rot as soon as you deploy
something to production it's probably
already too old because there's a newer
version already available and that
version could be fixing a vulnerability
that is in there
step one is knowing what your
application uses
also for your workflow files
and from there figure out what those
dependencies are doing for you
matching them against the no verbality
database and keeping that stuff up to
date
so some best practices there i hope you
are following these at least
make sure that not a single person can
do things depends on the maturity of
your team if your team does the entire
day
pair programming or they're so mature
that you can trust them that helps
but the amount of times that i've looked
at my own pull request and found some
issues there even if it's just a typo i
cannot count them anymore so it happens
to all of us
so it's best to at least have a fresh
set of eyes going over that
or do something in the pull request to
actually validate the things that you're
merging into your main branch
have that branch protection rule there
it used to be the the four eyes
principle from devops but there are
people who don't have two eyes so i
prefer the two-person principle now
it's a little bit more inclusive
but run something there validate that
your application still will do the
things that it should be doing maybe not
necessarily just in the b in the build
step but it could be a temporal
deployment where you actually validate
it everything still works and the build
step run at least the unit has for
example
figuring out who made these changes and
since your workflow files in there this
is really important for the code you can
go back to the git commit history your
workflow file is part of the code so you
can find out who made changes there as
well
you have a pull request attached to that
so you can figure out which two people
have committed that
change and approve that
everything that is around your code is
stored inside of the audit log inside of
github that's really easy that is there
on other platforms you sometimes need to
search for it
and then the auto log you can go to a
repository in this case the organization
and go to the auto log through settings
any auto log is anything that is
happening outside of the source code
realm
who got somebody who gave somebody
access to your source code
who made changes there who created a
personal access token to do something
with that source code
even inside of github when somebody
enables a feature on the repository like
enabling discussions that are stored
inside of your order log
you can output that into your scene and
your team can make some analysis there
figuring out what is happening in the
normal patterns and then the outliers
can be triggered for example triggering
an alert that information is available
inside of github
so be aware i had edited this
um
this is an example on the account level
this is my account so if you go to
settings and you can find it under the
security log they need it differently
there but also for yourself and on your
account that's very helpful and that you
can see what is happening there
all right that was just your repository
and everything that is in there
oftentimes we still forget that because
we're focusing on the platform or the
things that we run or just the supply
chain but your code is just as important
in preventing all of those supply chain
attacks
let's talk a little bit about those
runners the runners are the things that
execute your workflow files
there's some compute somewhere and you
got two options there you can run them
on a self-hosted setup where you install
a virtual machine install a runner on
there and from that start executing and
we also have github hosted runners
where github is hosting the compute for
you and they do everything for you
that comes of course with
responsibilities as well
if you have a self-hosted runner that
means that all the operating system
things that you need to update but all
the tools that you install there as well
are now your responsibility and you need
to fix it
it's nice that it enables you that a
specific environment setup the github
hosted runners for example currently
don't have gpu so if you do something
machine learning there
then you probably have a good reason to
start using cell phone runners there's
also no users limits on there for the
get opposite runners you need to pay for
the compute because they're maintaining
that for you of course you pay that by
the minute and you've got some minutes
in the package that you have so if you
have a teams account and you've got some
minutes in there i think enterprise
usually has 50 000 minutes a month
that you run on
and if you go over that then there's a
fee that is implied but that means that
all that operating system and the tools
and the security updates are now
github's
responsibility so apart you're paying
for that as well
but it gives us at least an option and
to use that
if you use self-hosted runners but also
for cloud platform you need to start
thinking about security
and on the face of it i trust github
that they can do lots of cool things
that they have a good security team but
still it is running somewhere and we
need to be aware of what happens on that
environment
especially if you run them yourself you
need to be aware of the scopes that you
give that runner what can it do inside
of your network
is it behind your company firewall
because you have a test that needs to
test against the database something
simple it happens
but also think about persisting state
between runs
what if it outputs your the binaries the
artifact that it delivers and outputs
down to a network share
i've seen companies doing the whole cicd
system on a company-wide shared
networking share
where they said well we just pick up the
library from there and we start
executing it
if you have a cell phone runner that is
your responsibility and also for the
user that it is using of course if you
can if you give it networking access it
can start traversing the network
as i said before the runner will
download the entire repository of any
action that it needs to execute
with all the binaries and everything
that is in that repository so be very
aware of what that action is doing for
you
because it will download that behind the
company firewall and will stay there
until somebody cleans it up
one of the
options you got there
is to run the action itself inside of
your container in this case we're
spinning up a container gradle in it and
that will do all the things that we need
to do in there this is one step but you
can also do that on the job level the
job here is test box and all these steps
in here will run inside of this
container
so the checkout will download my source
code inside of the container
and then i can run and check which java
version we're using very helpful because
it also means that i don't need to
install java all my runners i don't need
to install pre-prepared machines there
because i tell my users
use that specific version hopefully this
comes somewhere internally and has been
checked and authorized as well use
something like artifactory and x-ray for
example
to know vulnerabilities in those images
as well
but the nice thing is this is a
container so it spins up does its thing
and afterwards we just cleaned up
limiting the attack factors that you
have on the runner environment
and i cannot repeat this enough we still
see this happen if you have self-hosted
runner never ever ever
use that blankly for public repositories
you can have a trigger in your workflow
that says when somebody sends me a pull
request i start executing the workflow
file
and since it's a public repository
anybody can create a fork and send in a
pull request
they can even change the workflow file
for you and then you're running that
code downloading the action on your
private runner behind your company
firewall
so hopefully you're thinking about this
and doing this in a sandbox part of the
network
but we see companies over and over
making the same mistakes
run it somewhere in the network with too
much access so be very aware of these
responsibilities that you have setting
up the cicd system with this
yeah this is an example of course you've
got your repository somebody creates a
fork adds up malicious code
creates a pull request and now that
workflow executes on your self-hosted
runner with all access you gave it and
all the networking stuff that has access
to
but also potentially access to your
secrets your cloud deployment keys
any ssl certificate that is installed on
the machine
this is for the execution part
persisting data between runs is just as
dangerous not only the actions are being
downloaded but if you output something
for example you use a dependency cache
locally because your package manager
supports that
it does speed up your build because
you've got a cache there
but the second run could override those
uh cached versions
and then the next build will pick up
that malicious dependency and now you've
got a malicious dependency in your
artifact
you might say ah that doesn't happen
i'll wear a security conference right um
this is exactly what happened with the
solar gate attack this is a super
interesting read read on the depth of
things that they did here this one is
case sensitive so be aware if you use
that i'm sharing the slides afterwards
anyway
um so then you can click on it it helps
but this was super a big attack that
we've seen where they did exactly this
they even went so far that they detected
when there were processes running on the
machine that could potentially detect
them
in that case they shut everything off
and that way they evaded detection for
two and a half months i think
they overrode i think it was binary
they did had some extra attack factors
there they overrode one binary and that
got
included in the build artifact
that artifact got delivered to three and
a half thousand customers
who all updated to the latest version
so this is a real life case that you
need to be aware of and that's why i'm
so hammering on we need to update our
cdi cd pipelines and make sure that we
know what is happening inside of them
and github action is one of them
and they have the same issues as other
platforms as well
i'm hoping to at least instill that
messaging you you need to be aware of
what those things are doing for you
similar for that
don't share those runners
you can say i create one virtual machine
i install 10 different runners on that
and now i can share the compute
we used to do that
hopefully
you can see the risks here
because those runners have too much
access on those machines
and they can start escaping the sandbox
that they have they can override the
package cache centrally because they
centrally manage on the virtual machine
level
so have a way to use a runner one time
and afterwards clean it up
that's what github does for the cell
phones for the get a posted runners as
well they only exist for one execution
run and afterwards they get cleaned up
there are ways from the community where
you can spin these up inside of a
kubernetes cluster it will only exist
for that one execution then it dies and
we spin up a new one
so be aware of all of those risks
that was only the hosting part
now we need to dive into the actions
as i said the actions are open source um
you can use them from private or
internal repositories that's a little
bit more secure depending on who's
creating them but by default those 12
and a half 1 000 actions that were there
those are public repositories that means
you can go in there figure out the
history who's working on them and build
on top of that
they don't need to be
published to the marketplace any public
repository will work
so the attack factor is even worse
larger
you can go to the marketplace then you
can say i want to use the latest version
and then give you a pop-up that says
well if you copy and paste this part
over then you done that in your workflow
file you're good to go
this is each and every single demo
the nice thing is that that uses part
you can pick up that part and paste it
behind github.com and now you've got the
direct url to the public repository
which means you can see what that thing
is doing
start at least there this is already
where the demos stop they say hey copy
and paste this and then you're good to
go
i'll first figure out what the hell is
in our repository and what's actually
doing for you
they also have a version attached to
that this is now the default it used to
be optional but you need to attach a
version and this follows semantic
versioning so the first version
indicates
in this case version zero they're still
building up this is a minor and this is
a patch anytime those last two numbers
updates always backwards compatible if
there's a breaking change and the first
number changes and you need to make a
decision there's a breaking change can
you absorb that change
important for
an upcoming slide
as i said this is a public repository
what the hell are we executing to build
our own software
so i'm not even talking about all the
vulnerabilities in our software this is
just our power plants
and the more i dive into this the more
scary that i find this and this is why i
hate that all the demos stop it and just
copy and paste the example
while we're downloading a repository
there's nothing on the repository that
tells us this has been
validated by somebody it's up to you
we deliver it we rely on the open source
community here and you're part of it as
soon as you start using this
i already mentioned some of these attack
factors data theft exfiltrating ssh keys
on the machine
data integrity breaches of course but
also availability now
we've had those outages the last couple
of weeks with github
all of a sudden you couldn't download
your actions which also meant all of
your runners failed
even if you have self-hosted runners
even if you're using enterprise server
on-prem
they were still downloading the public
repositories
with that as we are all doing ci cd if i
find a zero-day application and i know
that you're using github actions i now
got a targeted way to block you from
updating
your production environment
now this is where it starts
figure out what an action is doing
there is nothing to protect you there
go to the action repository figure out
what it's doing if it's using container
images
any dependencies most of the actions run
on typescript and we've seen that a
couple of times now in supply chains
those packages will use packages those
packages will use packages and i can go
on for half an hour
we have the whole supply chain there
that we need to be aware of
so the first
step is at least start looking at those
things and figure out what they do
as i said that uses part you can copy
and paste that behind github.com if that
is a public repository and it has an
action.yaml in there you can start using
it as an action and this is of course
the most awesome things in sliced bread
non-home rule you must use the action
guess where i got that example of adding
spaces in your secret
public repository specifically not
published to the marketplace to make a
point but it is there
if you go to that repository then
there's a nice banner that says hey you
can use this one this one is on the
marketplace
you can search there so my initial
reaction was oh awesome
there's a marketplace so there should be
a verification process
azure devops at least pretends that it
has a process
if you publish something then they wait
a couple of hours before it is available
so they are doing something
in this case if you start an action in
policies in the marketplace it's
instantly available
that's fine
uh yeah i'll do that in the next line
so the marketplace doesn't really have a
verification process so what are we
doing we're pulling in a random
repository maybe behind your company
firewall
you can go to marketplace and there's a
check mark there and we've all learned
from the internet check marks are
indicating that it is great
you can go there and it says well this
is created that action that repository
comes from a verified creator
when this started i started looking at
for what the hell does that mean there's
a link there
that doesn't give you any information
what it means
eventually after
i think was a year and a half they
published a page on how to become a
verified creator on the marketplace
you need to have your github profile
present and accurate that means you have
an email address and that has been
verified
the organization that publishes the
repository that needs to have two-factor
authentication so all of a sudden it
cannot be a personal repository anymore
you need to create an organization
and that has two-factor authentication
enabled for the organization so anybody
who's contributing and that repo needs
to have two-factor authentication okay
that's a good point
and that organization is linked to a
domain
and that is verified through a tax
record
i think you're all aware of how easy it
is to get a domain and a tax record and
then say i'm verified
i went through this process myself
because i still didn't believe it
and this is exactly what it is
it was even nice because i went through
these steps and there's a click that
says verify and they told me yeah you're
now verified and wasn't showing up
anywhere i had to make a call to some
friends there and they said well we need
to do something manually and now the
check mark is visible
so that check mark
is not good enough
you can go into your organization or the
repository or even the enterprise and
there you can set permissions you could
say i'm now so scared that i'm going to
disable actions entirely for any
repository because this is weird stuff
well the option here is of course allow
select actions and those should be
pre-populated with actions that you have
actually validated
the default check mark is already saying
allow actions created by github
there's no reason
in the documentation anywhere
that indicates what this means
is this in the slash github organization
is it in the slash actions organization
is github the maintainer of this thing
i sort of trust them but
if they don't have a transparent process
for this
i hate it
i think if you have that one verified
creators i think that was clear i really
don't trust that they say that in the
documentation yeah you trust us on blue
eyes well i don't so the better option
is to say specified actions and you've
got a whole scala of wild card options
here is trust actions from that
organization because i know the
maintainer and you can even indicate
specific action repositories there on
even specific versions
so that's at least a good way you went
and did the work
verified that version and said well okay
i've seen the code and now i can trust
that right
if you
enable specified actions at the
organization level for example and
somebody creates a workflow and tries to
trigger that and it doesn't match your
allow list then you get an error
indicating go back to somebody with
ammunition
writes on the repository organization
level
call that person
that's very nice so at least we've got a
sense of we have securities a little bit
as i said this uses semantic versioning
and initially in the first half year
they said well please start using the
action version and pin that
pinning is just including that add sign
and the version
name using semantic versioning so you
have the freedom there to use this as a
filter when somebody update this package
to 102 this one will download the new
version and this will will not because
you have pinned that version to
something
this is very common
only thing is this version comes from
the releases inside of github
it created at least released by creating
attack in git
and then you push that as a release and
now it has a tag inside of your git
history
should be fine
the problem with
tags is you can reuse them
i can add code in a repository use the
same tag and push a new release
with the same tag
so even if you use the full version for
pinning it this will still download
randomly new code that you have you
haven't verified
so this is still super scary
if you're using that version then you're
already gone because you're pulling in
every new version
it sounds nice but you're pulling in
weird code from the internet
i came prepared so this is the best
practice that i say start with start
with verification find what is in that
repository and add the shah hash please
for the love of all things
start here
then at least you can say
i'm doing something with security
because i'm doing the effort of
outputting that shot and adding it there
initially it was even the short version
of the show but they quickly realized
that that was not good enough so this is
the entire show
and this is unfortunately uh hard to
read for us humans so what's next
even better
start taking ownership of those things
allow that to local actions in
organization or only select actions from
an organization that is under your
control
this used to be the starting point for
actions
but now in each and every demo they just
gloss over that
create a separate organization and fork
that action over there that means that
nobody can add code anymore to that
repository
it's now on your control
you still get notifications if you set
it up correctly
that the maintainer has pushed updates
and then you have a way to validate
those incoming updates
at least you now have a way to control
those things
um
that's coming up next
because we're talking about these types
of attack factors
forks are public repositories and
somebody can send in a pull request and
now all of a sudden your workflow is
doing something else but also through
common fields in those workflow files
it's a cisd pipeline so it probably has
parameters somewhere along the line
this has at least already improved a lot
there are three different types where
you can start running code
a push but on a fork that only runs on
their end they need to enable the
workflow on there and then can happen so
it's relatively safe for us
and on the pull request
when somebody creates a pull request
from a fork and you have the pull
request trigger that will trigger your
profile on your environment
but we learned the hard way that this is
insecure because we're now pulling in
changes from a fork
and we said well this only runs on the
server on the merge commit and will only
get rid of only access to things like
our secrets
initially we just gave the secrets and
say hey you can now deploy into a cloud
environment
the full weakest target is then the
newer one and that has super high risk
it will have read and write access so we
inject the secrets there and what we
usually say protect yourself start with
the first workflow to indicate we did a
check we did for example a verification
on the yaml file
try to remediate the risk and then you
can say i still want to run on the pull
request because i need to validate on
our own test environment for example
but you need to have a check in front of
that
this is a super interesting read every
now and a while github has captured the
flag events for actions as well and they
say here's a repository try to get right
access into our main branch
the things they learn from that are
super interesting to see what we can
learn and try to protect ourselves from
these types of
attacks um
for the pull request i already mentioned
secrets there's a secret uh specific
secret the git up token
that gets instantiated for each and
every job
and as soon as the job has completed
this one has been revoked
but that token has by default read and
write permissions into your repository
so if this comes from somebody who has
write access into your repository they
can do things with that
it's very easy for all the many things i
can create a comment on an issue by
using the git toke
i currently don't like that this is
default of course it should be as less
actionable as possible and then i need
to decide do i want to give it
so be aware that this is the default
what you then can now do is give it less
permissions give it more granular
permissions by defining that in the
workflow file this is now all of a
sudden source code you can say that
github token can be created but it has
only right access to a pull request so
we can add comments to the pull request
in an automatic way
it doesn't need to have right access
into my content
preventing me from creating
extra commits in my repository from a
workflow file
um
i'm not 100 sure if this will can be
used to merge i don't think so
but i'm not 100 sure
that's a good one i think it only has
access to the the pull request itself so
the body and the the commands that are
in there but i'm not 100 sure
um
but then at least the token that you
inject inside of an action that will
only have that so limiting the blast
radius applies here try to confine it as
much as we can
through those captured flag events we've
also seen attacks through all of these
types of fields that you can use it's
very nice for us as automators i can
read the title of your issue that you're
inputting but this is user input i've
seen several sessions on the conference
that say don't use user input
don't trust it by default
i've got an example here of an action in
this case is a shell script that uses
the title from the issue that triggered
the workflow execution
and i do so my regular expression with
that figure out what i need to do and
otherwise i echo something out well that
part is of course interesting
this is all done by stringer
interpolation
so if i give this payload and end that
string a little bit early now i've got
actionable code inside of my shell
script
super simple
but this is user content so do not trust
it we've seen a capture the flag event
where somebody had crafted a specific
name of a branch
and that way they got right access into
the repository by escalating their
privileges
this is a way to prevent that make sure
that you inject it as an environment
variable then it will not be interpreted
and you can use single quotes of course
on a shell script to make sure that it's
not an interpreted string it's a really
simple mistake to make
so that part was
hopefully scaring you all a little bit
now i've got a way that i use and i
advise my customers to use that as well
we're implementing that currently again
at a customer
of taking ownership of all those actions
and then have a good way to at least
stay up to date and do the verifications
that we need to do
those forking of actions that i
mentioned
it has more pros and cons in my opinion
but the calls are really there
it will be more secure because you're
taking ownership you have a point in
time where you can do the validation
and you can say okay i've done that i've
forked it over to my organization so
it's now under my control it also gives
me a nice way of backing that up in case
the maintainer of that action wins the
lottery for example and they go and go
do something again weird
um
you still have a backup they might
rename the action there are ways to
remediate that as well get up and works
around renaming and moving it into
organizations pretty well but it's just
through a redirect and it happens to
work
so taking a bit of ownership really
helps there but it also gives you more
maintenance work you need to create
those forks you need to have an
organization that can create an org you
need to have a set of
devops engineers if you want to
who are responsible for that and keeping
that up to date
and you've now said allow only these
actions from that organization so it's a
speed bump of using new actions in your
organization
i use a in an actual organization to
test these things out with the test code
to make this as safe as possible there
but it has some cons as well
this should be a starting point
because then the onus is up to you
you've already done some validations and
those validations usually are manually
i haven't included that in these slides
i've got a blog post of how you can then
do all those validations what we can do
to automate that using dependable
updates for example and stuff like that
but i left that out of the presentation
for today
because i can talk for that for an hour
as well
now you got a fork and now you need to
keep it up to date and that was my
starting point initially
and from that you can build out the rest
because as i said we have 12 and a half
thousand actions it's all open source
and most of them are pretty active
so they are updated uh every other day
do you wait for a deprecation message on
the repository there
we only have a version available inside
of git
github
how the hell can we stay up to date
do we want to create some automation
that updates that with a pull request on
our end
you need to read all the changes in that
source code repository and staying up to
date is super hard there's a marketplace
and that's it there's no rss feed
there's nothing there that was available
and when i started was only
a couple thousand packages so that was
still doable and i was frustrated
because i couldn't see what people in
our community are building on top of
that
and i'm a good nerd so i built something
for myself
i've got a twitter bot that tweets out
every three hours it checks the entire
marketplace sees our version updates and
new stuff available in that case it will
tweet out
this is already drinking from the
firehose because the community is super
active in creating these things and
updating them
but still the new stuff that i've
learned already in here new technology
that i haven't
heard of before
it's cool stuff
so this could be a way to stay up to
date the other way is going to the the
marketplace and then do a diff on the
number of actions that they say that are
there and then start searching for them
of course so this is a bit a bit better
but this is interesting to see what pops
up here
the better way is for me split the two
two options that i want to give you it
always starts with review what the
action is doing that should be your
starting point do not blindly trust an
action repository it could be hidden
inside of the history somewhere
so super scary um the first one is use
actions and a commit shop
we've shown that pin the commits that's
a good practice at least start there
anything else then this can already help
you but do the verification first
then you can add dependable who here
already uses dependable knows what it is
okay a bit more than actions
the panel bolt is basically
a dependency checker
dependable has this whole software
composition analysis of your application
but it can also do that for the
ecosystem github actions
it can read all your workflow files it's
easily stored inside of a specific
directory
it has the same schedule as a normal
dependable and it will go through your
actions even with the commit sha saying
hey there's a new version available i
see you use the version tag so i update
sent you in the pull request with that
updated version or with the updated sha
super easy
so that's very helpful but now you're
getting pull requests
for each and every time one of those
action updates happens
depending on the action that you're
using
something like the checkout action that
probably gets an update each and every
week because they're actively checking
their dependencies as well
and if the action slash checkout action
is updated probably 80 of your
repositories will get a pull request
stating you need to update your workload
file so this could be a little bit
cumbersome but at least it is there and
it already helps
um
i already gave away my dependable stuff
and dependable will check your
repository check the um
actions file and then here you see an
example that it says the trx parts that
i use to output my unit test it has an
update from zero zero three to zero zero
five and it will then send in the pull
request with only that change
they've now even enabled it that
dependable is showing this as
dependencies inside of your repository
which also means that you can go to the
checkout action and find out all of the
40 million repositories that are using
that action so it's now bringing
visibility into the ecosystem how
actively is this being used
only works for public repositories where
you can show that but we have that now
included as part of the supply chain
so i really like that as well
um yeah that was the update of course
even better
is improving this setup because i don't
want to approve
20 something pull requests across all
the repositories that i have on each and
every monday that's a great way to start
your week of course
reviewing each and every time the same
pull request
start by reviewing the action and fork
the action repository
you can see that this is a fork of
course
um and then you can say i'm going to
wait until this huge banner appears on
the repository but who goes into each
and every of their dependencies and
checks for their message of course
that's not doable so we want to automate
that as well and i'm a devops engineer
and search for it long and hard because
i really don't want to try and create
everything and fix for every issue that
i see but i couldn't find an option
there
and when i can find an option and it
really bothers me then i start creating
it
so i've got a repository you get a fork
updater you can fork that configure it
and it will update all of your forks
it goes through all the forks inside of
an organization
runs on a schedule so that's easy we're
using actions and workflows for that as
well
it would then create an issue saying hey
you've got an outdated repository
click on this information
and you get that message this is stored
inside of the github fork updater so you
can for example
subscribe to notifications from your
devops team and they can all manage that
give them the authority to do that and
you can even create workflow files that
then automatically will assign it to
your team for example you can do all
sorts of automation on there
but the important part is that i give
you a compare link and if you click on
that link then it will exactly tell you
we're coming from the fork and we're
figuring out what is happening there
um
and
on the
is even shown here there's a tab where
you can see the actual code changes in
here this is not a good enough example i
should update that
but you can see all those incoming
commits that were made on the action
repository so you can validate again
these are the changes i made my base
validation these are the changes is this
good enough and then you can make a
decision there
making a decision is adding a label
only people would maintain access can
add labels on pull requests
and issues so this is a good security
measure
and your team can do the validation
there at their own time and add a label
adding a label is a trigger for workflow
file so that workflow file can now do
the work and update that fork for me
automatically i don't have to care
anymore
and it even then closes the comment of
comments on the issue and closes the
issue now we're done
easy pc in that case
yeah you should then get close
so this goes back to my list of pros of
forking you've got a backup of the
action
you have full control over updates now
you're pulling in all the updates
centrally so you don't have to manage
dependable in 20 different repositories
with 20 different pull requests for 20
times the same action
so you have a level of trust here i can
then say i only want to allow actions
for my actions organization
which then also makes my life easier
because now i can say i want to skip
figuring out the commit shaft for each
and every action
and then going across all my
repositories doing the maintenance
figuring out if it's there i have a good
security harness now
so i can say everybody can at least go
back to version
attacks because now it's under my
control i have a little bit more insight
into that
so the most important thing is that it
skips adding dependable teaching every
year
i've got a blog post with all of those
steps in here and all the maturity
levels that i've seen there so if you
want to follow along with that read that
that helps you guide you through the
entire process and where you can learn
more
and with that i hope that i scared you
at least a little bit and you woke up
don't start using the defaults and don't
check the demos
follow up on this and figure out what
you can improve there
i gave an overview of all those best
practices this is a nice summary
overview
and start there those secrets are very
scary in my opinion
especially if you have a public
repository
start by looking what those things are
doing for you the runner downloads the
entire repository on your end and
does something with that
i even have a proof of concept where the
first thing in my workflow is my script
and my script will check at all the
actions that have been downloaded any
workflow because that's the first thing
that it does
and then i can start overwriting them
and currently there's no integrity check
after that
so even if you have 10 actions that are
executed in your workflow file i can
control what they are doing
tough luck figuring that out if i do it
properly in a good way
i'm still bothering it out to fix that
but they're not there yet
fork the action repository limit to
local actions make sure that you have it
under control i currently have an
environment where we gave 600 developers
the opportunity to use any action from
the marketplace
and we are trying to remediate that way
too late we're after the fact
and on sale for the runner so that's
even worse
when we need to try to protect ourselves
against these
it will create a burden and a little bit
of speed bumps have an organization to
test with be aware of that as well don't
just block everything because that's a
way to kill innovation of course
and then i think i gave you a good way
to keep your actions up to date
there are more steps after this you can
set up your own internal marketplace for
example where people can search in your
internal actions
you can create updates from that and
newsletters but that's all follow-up
stuff
my main point is
think about security in this case
because it's very scary to me the more
that i learn about this platform the
more scared i am
so with that if you have any questions
just come over here and ask them i still
have some time before i need to run to
the airport
and fly back my name is rob
i live in the netherlands you can follow
me on twitter or figure out what i'm
doing through my blog post there's lots
of stuff and actions in there
thank you so much
[Applause]
you